did you know that in one piece there are
18 different races and that three of
them can actually control elements like
water and fire or that we have confirmed
proof of a 1,000 yearlong war that began
well before the void Century or that
there are three ancient magical trees
that are all thousands of years old and
that one of them might even grow inside
of the red line well today we're going
to dive down the one piece lore Iceberg
going from the most surface level lore
that even the most casual one piece fans
should know about down to the absolute
deepest and darkest secrets of tier
number six where the most secret and
wild lore facts about One Piece are
hidden like The crucial role that the
whales play in protecting the one piece
but for now we're starting off with tier
level one or the tip of the iceberg
still above the surface and why not kick
things off with the lore that is so
important it is literally the title of
the story and that is of of course the
actual one piece treasure which inspired
the great age of piracy and send Pirates
like Luffy to chase after this mythical
treasure now there are in fact many many
things that we do know about the one
piece for example we do know that it is
supposed to be located on LT tale which
is the final island of the grand line
and on top of that the author is also
told us that the actual one piece
treasure isn't just something cheesy
like the friends we made along the way
or something like that no it is
something physical and real in fact the
treasure is supposed to include
something that was left behind by a
legendary figure from the past and it
also includes all of the former pirate
king Goldie rogers's treasure as well
plus Roger and his crew are so far as we
know the only people to have ever found
this island love Tale in over 800 years
so even though this Iceberg contains
tons of mindblowing answers to one piece
Biggest Secrets this one mystery is one
that is still unanswered even to this
day and if you have ever read or watched
all of One Piece then you should know
about the poneglyphs as well which are
these giant unbreakable stones that tell
the ancient history of the so-called
void Century now don't worry we will be
talking about the void Century in a lot
more detail in just a moment but the
most important poneglyphs out of these
are the so-called Four Road poneglyphs
which contain the information that you
need in order to find the island love
Tale in fact these four are so important
that the strongest pirates in the world
try to regularly find or steal them so
that they can actually be the ones to
finally find the one piece and become
the next pirate king however these red
poneglyphs are far from the only
versions of these Stones which were
hidden all around the world by the
so-called ancient Kingdom and without
getting too deep into tier 2 Iceberg
territory quite yet the ancient kingdom
is a kingdom that basically ruled over
the world before the current world
government defeated them sometime
between 8 and 900 years ago now the
reasons for for why and how the world
government might have defeated the
ancient kingdoms are too spicy for just
tier level one so we'll be saving that
information for just a few more minutes
down the iceberg so for now just know
that the current world government
somehow defeated this ancient Kingdom
and took overpower now the worst thing
about this though is that the world
government then decided that all history
of that time period needed to be
completely erased as a result this is
why that period of time is now called
the void Century because almost all
information about it has been completely
wiped from the history books all texts
about it were destroyed important people
who knew anything about it were killed
and even to this day anyone who
researches the void Century or the ponl
for that fact is hunted down and killed
by the world government as we for
example saw during Robin's flashback now
I've already mentioned the grand line
which is the stretch of water right here
where all the strongest Pirates and
Marines are located but did you know
that it also has some important
important lore regarding the world as a
whole because during the baraa arc we
actually learned that sanji's dream is
to find the mythical all blue in case
you forgot the all blue is rumored to be
a place in the world where the water
from all four blues the South Blue East
blue West Blue and North Blue meat and
what makes it so special to Sanji is
that this place is set to contain fish
that can't be found anywhere else in the
world and while we're all always excited
to see Sanji whip up some brand new
dishes here or there the important thing
for the lore of the world is that this
place currently doesn't seem to exist
because the world is separated by the
red line which is this massive Stone
barrier continent that goes all the way
around the world and the com Bells which
are these parallel stretches of water
that border the grand line and while you
might now say that the all blue does
exist right here I think we can safely
say that this isn't the all blue since
Sanji already passed this way and didn't
think that it was the all blue which
might mean that later on something will
happen to the red line and the four
blues will be reunited after all once
again however you might be surprised to
hear that this wasn't the only important
worldlord that was dropped early on in
the story because when we were
introduced to the warlord system just
before the arlong park Arc back in the
East blue we all of a sudden learned
that there were people out there way
stronger than anyone we had faced so far
now the important basics of the warlord
system are that the world government was
basically inviting strong Pirates to
work with them in exchange these Pirates
get their bounties Frozen and can
essentially do whatever they want as
long as they come when the world
government calls them to fight and for
now the only warlord that I want to
mention in tier number one is dracu
mihawk who we learned is the strongest
swordsman in the world and even used to
duel with the emperor redhair Shanks and
speaking of Shanks it's time to drop
some basic tier one lore about the
entire yonko or Emperor system of
pirates as well basically this system is
essentially made up of the four
strongest pirate Crews who dominate the
final part of the grand line which is
also called the new world they are so
powerful that even the world government
struggle to defeat even one of these
insanely powerful pirate crews in fact
it did take the world government plus
the combined strength of all the
Warlords to actually almost rival the
emperess which altogether creates the
three great powers of the one piece
world and these Emperors of the sea have
been Luffy's main right r s during the
second half of the story however you
might be surprised to learn that the
emperor system itself hasn't been around
forever because as far as we know it did
not even exist before Roger became
pirate king and the previous era of
piracy might have only been ruled by one
or two really strong pirate Crews but
now of course we can't talk about the
strongest Pirates without mentioning the
most wellknown abilities in one piece as
well I'm of course talking about devil
fruits and while the true Origins of
these Powers still somewhat remain a
mystery to this day many Legends
consider these fruits to be kind of like
pieces of the sea devil that take the
form of a fruit which means that by
eating that fruit you actually take a
piece of a sea devil inside of you
although all of this is just Legend and
there are some really strong theories
about the real origins of devil fruits
that we'll be getting into later on
however once a person does take a bite
of a fruit they instantly gain the
powers of that particular fruit for the
rest of their life the only real
downside here is that they can no longer
swim and will literally drown if they
fall into water besides that though it's
pretty commonly known that there is only
ever one of each devil fruit in the
world at a time so there can never be
two people with the exact same Powers oh
yeah and uh if you eat two devil fruits
then you'll explode at least that's
according to Legend but we've actually
seen someone do this in the story and
they were just fine so more on this
later but one of the most interesting
things about the one piece lure is that
there are many races in the one piece
world that have their own unique
Elemental abilities for example the
animal mink tribe have natural
electricity the fishermen can control
water to some degree at least and these
angel-like creatures even have natural
firep powers and these are just some of
the many many races in one piece though
because besides humans there are also
Giants dwarfs long arm leg neck people
wined people and much much more that
we'll discuss later and what's most
incredible here though is that all of
these races have very detailed histories
that connect together back to the void
Century in fact many of these races were
even friends of the ancient Kingdom and
still protect the poneglyphs from the
world government to this day and now
before we get deeper into this Iceberg
below the surface here's a fact that
you've probably heard even if you
haven't watched or read one piece at all
and and that is that Luffy's childhood
friend Ace is actually the son of the
former pirate king Goldie Roger oh yeah
and he also died at the climax of The
Marine Ford War which uh as far as we
know ended the bloodline of the former
pirate king for good however in one way
both Ace and Roger are actually still
alive shocking right I know but that's
because we're going to start tier level
two below the surface with the idea of
inherited will now this is kind of the
part of the iceberg like below the
surface which represents Lord that you
most likely must have picked up if
you've watched or read one piece more
than once and inherited will is one of
those super super important Concepts
that you probably don't remember if
you're a casual viewer only and
basically the idea behind inherited will
is that if someone dies without
fulfilling their dream or purpose then
someone else who comes after them can
inherit their will and continue their
dream for them technically keeping them
alive in some way or form in fact this
can even apply to entire Generations
passing on their will to Future
generations and this is probably best
shown by Roger himself and the emperor
Whitebeard who both weren't able to
bring true peace to the world but passed
their dreams onto the Next Generation
and to explain that a little bit further
Roger found the one piece but actually
according to himself was too early to
use whatever information or power was
left from the void century and so
because he ended up having an incurable
disease and was about to die anyways he
turned himself into the Marines this
then gave him a huge public platform for
his execution which led him to inspire
the entire next generation of pirates to
go search for the one piece and pretty
much the same thing can be said of
Whitebeard as well because with his
dying breath he confirmed that the one
piece was in fact real which further
inspired hope for the current generation
like Luffy to actually go and continue
searching for this legendary treasure
but this idea of inherited will a
central theme in the story works on on a
much smaller level as well as many of
the straw hats have even inherited the
will of their prior mentors as their own
dreams for example Chopper wanting to
become a great doctor like his first
mentor and Robin inheriting the will of
the scholars of Ohara to find out what
happened during the void Century now
before we move much further here though
let's dive in a little bit more about
the actual one piece and the void
Century here because I just said that
Roger was too early to use what we left
on L tail which means that we need to
ask exactly what this legendary treasure
actually is well there are a few
possibilities but to truly understand
the possibilities we first have to take
a look at the people we actually know
from the void century and what they
could have possibly left behind and the
first and most important of these people
is a legendary figure called Joy boy and
the very first time that we hear about
this character was actually during the
fisherman island arc after the time skip
when we learned that Joy boy wrote A
mysterious ious letter of apology to a
former mermaid princess about a promise
that he was not able to keep now we
don't know exactly what that promise
specifically was but we can guess that
it probably involves the fishermen
having to live at the bottom of the sea
to escape oppression up on the surface
and joy boy helping them to get back to
that surface which leads us to the
probably most mysterious event and time
period in all of One Piece which is the
war between the ancient Kingdom and the
20 kingdoms who later founded the world
government
and while we still don't know a ton
about what exactly happened we do know
that somehow the 20 kingdoms won the
ancient kingdom was destroyed and the
poneglyphs were created by the ancient
Kingdom to keep the world government
from completely erasing the ancient
Kingdom's history and keeping some hope
for future Generations now interestingly
enough we do actually know that these
unbreakable Stones were created by the
kuki clan from wano who are just one of
the many many confirmed allies of that
former ancient Kingdom however after
this Great War the world government was
then formed by the 20 kingdoms and they
have ruled the world together ever since
as for the ancient Kingdom we don't
really know if they had an actual home
island or Home Country somewhere in the
world it could have of course been L
tail itself or it could have been an
island destroyed long long ago but we do
know that all of the known allies of the
ancient kingdom are not allies of the
world governments for example the
samurai of wano the sky people the
fishermen minks and we assume even the
Giants of albu as well plus as we
learned during the wanu arc there is
also a legendary figure called na who
was known as the Sun God now we don't
really know if Joy boy and the sun god
were the same people in theory both of
these could just be titles that many
different people could have inherited
throughout the centuries but we do know
that Luffy has now awakened his devil
fruit called the NAA fruit and inherited
both Nika's and joy boy's will to bring
freedom to the world s and now while
much of the lore of the ancient kingdom
is still very much hidden there are some
absolute facts that we do know for sure
about that time period as well first of
all is that this giant ship here was
created in order to carry all of the
fishermen and merfolk from the bottom of
the ocean up to the surface we kind of
assumed that this was part of Joy boy's
promise to that mermaid princess back
when he was not able to keep it and with
all of this that we've been reviewing
about the ancient Kingdom I think we can
get a pretty good idea about what the
one piece actually might be because it
does seem like the main idea that is
usually associated with joy boy and NAA
is the idea of freedom for the many many
races of oppressed people around the
world and so the one piece has to be at
least somehow related to freeing the
world right if that's true the one piece
could be some sort of powerful weapon or
maybe even some sort of information that
will help defeat the world governments
however while Joy boy is the ancient
figure we are most excited to learn
learn about there is one other legendary
ancient hero that we have actually met
in the story and that's because the
sword God theuma from wano was turned
into a zombie that Zoro then forged
during the Thrilla bark art and while
this was the very first time that we met
him we then later learned that theuma is
actually considered a national hero in
wano who once defended the country
during its own Golden Era what we don't
know is exactly how long ago Ruma
actually lived but it would make a lot
of sense to to me if he actually lived
sometime around the white Century since
it would his timeline line up pretty
nicely with some other important people
from that same time periods and in fact
sticking with the island of wano there's
actually some very interesting lure
regarding the actual geography of that
country because while we've had a few
maps showing the layout of this really
oddly shaped country there are a few
Mysteries surrounding the country's
Origins as well that's because if you
look at the map here it really does look
like wano is kind of made up of many
different islands that were kind of
pulled together into one bigger one and
what's even weirder is that the weather
patterns for each of these sections are
completely different from each other and
so if you combine that knowledge with
what we know about islands in the grand
line all having their own weather
patterns then it makes a lot of sense
that this island of wano that exists
above the water might have once actually
been several different islands that Were
Somehow smushed together to create this
new bigger wano country and funnily
enough we even have a rise of extra big
giants who are literally called
continent pullers so that is just one
more piece of evidence to support this
potential lore right here and now you
might be wondering why wano would be
created like this in the first place and
one possible answer might come from the
lore surrounding slavery in one piece
because even though slavery is
technically outlawed by the world
government it very much clearly still
exists as we see with the Slate auction
house during the sabat OD Arc plus the
fact that the celestial dragons
themselves right around ons slaves and
use slaves to operate their giant moving
walkway and this connects to wano plus
many of the other allies of the ancient
Kingdom because there is some evidence
to suggest that the world government and
even people who ruled the world before
them used to enslave many of the people
and races from around the one piece
world for example about 1,000 years
before the presence storyline the animal
mink tribe moved their entire population
to live on the back of this giant
elephant why did they do that well the
most likely reason is to escape the
oppression just like the fishermen who
moved to the bottom of the ocean we also
have a dwarf tribe that we met in Dres
Rosa who once fled their Kingdom and
were later enslaved by the ruling family
of Dres Rosa and these dwarfs were only
freed once that ruling family actually
moved to the top of the red line to to
become Celestial dragons after the void
Century as part of the 20 kingdoms that
founded it in other words clearly
slavery has been a really big deal for a
very long time in one piece and to bring
this all back to wano it is very
possible that wano itself was created as
a sort of sanctuary to protect a group
of humans and other races from the
oppression of other humans or some other
super powerful race in fact speaking of
powerful races there is none more
powerful in one piece than the lunarians
here whose introduction near the end of
the wano arc absolutely blew everyone's
mind and that is because this race of
angelic winged people once actually
lived on top of the red line before they
were almost completely wiped out not
only that in fact they were once
actually referred to as a tribe of
literal Gods which does make me think
that they probably ones actually ruled
over the world similarly to how humans
rule the one piece world right now and
to explain what makes them so so
powerful the lunarians get their
incredible powers from this magical
flame on their back which allows them to
create fire and become nearly Invincible
while that flame is active and now you
might be wondering how they were
defeated if they were so incredibly
powerful but that's a bit of lore too
juicy for tier number two so we'll
discuss it a lot further down this
Iceberg and anyways what is more
important here though is that the
current most individually powerful race
is with without a doubt the race of
giants because come on these people are
simply massive and their average Warrior
is easily worth at least 100 regular
humans and most Giants come from the
legendary island of elb but what you
might not know is that Giants actually
live in many places around the world as
we learned during Robin's flashback as
well but honestly if there's one Island
everyone's very excited to Wiz it it's
definitely elb because it has some truly
insane lore first off the entire island
is basically based off of Norse
mythology and we can kind of see that
based on the design of their
architecture the name of their ruler is
Loki who is the Norse god of trickery
and Mischief or God of stories and also
the fact that there is this giant tree
sometimes shown in the background of elb
which reminds me of the world tree Yik
drail from Norse mythology however while
it is likely inspired by that mythical
tree we most likely already know that
this tree's real name in one piece is
the treasure tree atam now in case you
forgot we learned during the water 7 Arc
that the wood from this atom tree is
unbelievably strong so much so that
Frankie made the straw Hat's new ship
the Thousand Sunny out of that wood plus
we do know that this tree is located in
a very warart torn country which
perfectly fits elb and actually while
we're talking about that treasure tree
atom this is the perfect time to mention
that there are actually some other super
important trees in the one piece world
as well well the second is the sunlight
tree Eve which we first learned about
during the fisherman island arc This
truly incredible tree absorbs sunlight
and then filters down light and oxygen
to the roots of it that are located at
the bottom of the ocean right above
Fishman Island and what you may not
realize here is that we don't actually
know where the top of that tree actually
is located you might assume that it is
directly above Fishman Island since that
is where its roots are but that is never
actually confirmed confed and right
above Fishman island is actually the
giant red line so unless the sunlight
tree is somehow part of the red line
inside of it or on top of it then it
could very well be located somewhere
else entirely and continuing with the
theme of biblical references there is
also the tree of knowledge that was
located on the island of Ohara before it
was then destroyed by the world
government this also massive tree served
as the home base for the Scholars of
aara who were a group that were
dedicated to researching the poneglyphs
and the history this of course ended up
leading to their destruction when the
world government finally came and
destroyed the island with a so-called
Buster call which tragically also burned
down this truly magnificent tree of
knowledge and while we don't know if
this tree actually had any sort of
special characteristics like the Adam or
the eve tree the planting of the tree of
knowledge itself is actually the oldest
confirmed event in all of One Piece lore
which took place about 5,000 years
before the current storyline now that's
of course not to say that the two other
trees can't be older though we just
don't know for sure at this point and in
fact one thing that may hint at the
treasure tree atom being way older than
that is its sheer size I mean we haven't
ever seen a full clear picture of it yet
but there have been hints that this tree
is truly truly massive like this image
right here in fact it is so massive that
we know it might even reach up to the
sky island level itself and this was
actually hinted at during the skypia arc
when we learned that there is something
called the path of the high West which
is the regular official way that usually
people reach the sky islands from and
from this we can speculate that it must
somehow be some sort of massive Safe Way
for people to actually reach the sky
islands which just makes a lot of sense
for that then to be this incredibly huge
tree plus we do have these giant Vines
such as the giant Jack that could even
be branches that spread out from this
massive tree and actually now that we
are on top of the sky people we simply
have to mention the fascinating lore
Behind These winged races that you
actually might have missed if you've
only watched the anime and that's
because during annel's cover story in
the manga we learned that the sky people
once lived up on the moon now it is a
bit of a mystery when they lived there
or for how long but one thing that is
certain is that they were once up on the
moon and later had to descend s down to
earth which is actually how two of the
sky races at least ended up on the
clouds while the third race found
themselves down on the island of Gia and
it was actually very important that this
shandan tribe came down to the blue sea
because they eventually also became an
ally of the ancient Kingdom we know this
because they have long guarded a
poneglyph that contains the secret
location of an ancient weapon which we
will be discussing more about in just a
moment but for now the shandians used to
be an incredibly wealthy Society even
making an entire city out of gold but
their downfall started when they became
involved in some sort of major war most
likely during the battle against the 20
kingdoms during the void century and we
actually learn all of this during the
flashback during the skypia arc which
told us the story of Nolan the liar now
the important lore to know from this
flashback is that ever since the void
Century the shanan people were
protecting the Golden City of shandora
and the poneglyphs until a super
powerful water burst shot part of their
Island up into the sky around 400 years
ago this actually put the shandan people
back into conflict with the other winged
races and they continued their conflict
until Luffy and the straw hats brought
them together during the sky PR and
continuing with epic events from the
past 100 years ago the legendary
captains of the giant pirate crew
started their NeverEnding duel on the
island of little garden which is
actually kind of tragic if you think
about it because two friends nearly
killed each other over a simple
disagreement but honestly nothing is
probably as tragic in one piece as
Brook's backstory which contains a super
important hint about the secrets of the
one piece because around 50 years ago
the crew befriended a baby whale named
laboon who had been separated from its
family pots however the crew had to
leave laboon behind once they actually
entered the grand line and they promised
to return once they traveled around the
world now sadly the crew never made it
as they were wiped wied out completely
by a deadly disease and poison but the
important part about all of this is that
ever since that day the music loving
laboon was waiting for his crew to
return and while that never happened his
presence at the start of the grand line
is just a start of some sort of secret
lore regarding the one piece that we
will simply have to save for way way
down at the bottom of this Iceberg but
keep it in mind however for the entire
time that laboon was waiting for his
crew there was actually this old man who
was taking care of him because this is
crocus and man when we first met him I
don't think anyone would have believed
that he is one of the few people alive
who actually knows what the one piece
treasure actually is and that's because
we later learned that he was once a
member of Rogers crew when they actually
found the legendary treasure and aside
from crocus there's also one other man
who the straw hats met who also knows
what that treasure is and that's of
course Silver's ra here Roger's former
Vice Captain and surprisingly those are
the only two people we currently know of
who absolutely 100% for sure know what
that treasure is although to be fair
there might be others like the leaders
of the world government who might know
as well however if we had to pick any
other candidates to possibly know the
truth a very good choice would be the
world's greatest scientist Dr Vega Punk
and we'll actually be discussing more of
his lore and why he might know quite a
lot about the one piece in a deeper tier
but his basic backstory is that he is a
genius scientist who has worked for the
world government for many many years in
fact it is said that he's such a
scientific genius that he is
technologically 500 years more advanced
than anyone else in the entire world and
his Creations include things like these
destructive cyborgs and even a perfectly
cloned devil fruit but now for the final
piece of lore for tier number two we
simply have to include here the
Legendary Pirate Rox debec who nearly
conquered the entire world 38 eight
years ago this man was considered
Roger's greatest rival and he even
gathered a ridiculously powerful crew
full of future emperor of the Seas like
Whitebeard kaido and big mom however
what you may not realize about rocks is
that he most likely had some sort of
secret connection to the former pirate
king Goldy Roger and that they may have
actually once been friends but now
enough with this casual Normy level lore
because now it's time to dive deep into
tier level three which is lore that you
most likely know if you're plucked into
the one piece community and consume one
piece content outside of the main story
but that might be completely new to you
if you're not starting with the rest of
what we actually know about the void
Century because we've already
established that during this time period
there was a war between the ancient
Kingdom and the 20 Kings who went on to
form the world government yada y but
what you may not know is that the
ancient kingdom was made up of allies
from all over the world now we've
touched on a few of them so far but to
Tru trully understand this we need to
look at the most important clues that
they left behind about the history and
there of course I am talking again about
the poneglyphs and let's dive into
exactly what different kinds there are
and where we have found these ancient
texts in the world so we've already
discussed the four road poneglyphs which
point the way to love tale but they're
actually known to be 30 poneglyphs in
total scattered all throughout the world
nine of these are so-called riop
poneglyphs which tell the story of the
ancient Kingdom itself self while the
others contain messages from people or
information about the location of other
poneglyphs or secret weapons and
actually the first time in the story
that we learned about the poneglyphs was
in Alabaster in fact this poneglyph was
rumored to contain information about the
ancient weapon pluton that we will be
explaining in more detail in just a
minute but first since alabas protected
a poneglyph for 800 years that means
that this desert kingdom was very likely
an ally of the anci ancient Kingdom in
some way or form and in fact recently
the story has been shedding a lot more
light on this very complicated
relationship but we'll cover more of
that deeper down this Iceberg we also
found normal poneglyphs located in
skypia underneath this Golden Bell on
the island of Ohara and also on
fisherman Island we found this poneglyph
describing Joy boy's apology letter to
the mermaid princess now the next
poneglyph we found which finally opened
up the true nature of these Stones was
the road poneglyph on on top of the
giant elephant Zone and it was actually
at this point that the straw hats and as
the audience finally learned that in
order to find the one piece you would
need to gather all the road poneglyphs
just like Roger had done fortunately for
us the next two Road poneglyphs had
already been found and were under the
control of the emperor's big mom and
kaido and besides the road pag big mom
also held a few others which were also
copied when the straw heads broke into
Steel them which actually leads us to
wano and after after defeating kaido
Robin was able to read the road
poneglyph kept hidden in the depth of
wano under the water surface however
these weren't the only poneglyphs here
and it was during this final stretch of
the wano arc that we also learned that
the ancient weapon pluton that we
learned about in Alabaster was indeed
located in wano and Robin had known
about it ever since the alabaster Ark
and I think for now that's all we're
going to talk about the poneglyphs until
still deeper in the iceberg but let's
stay on the topic of the most powerful
weapons in the world which are the
ancient weapons and just you know to
recap there are three of these super
powerful weapons and their names are
Poseidon pluton and Uranus named after
Greek gods now at this point we do know
for sure that Poseidon is the power to
control the gigantic sea Kings in fact
the current mermaid princess shirahoshi
was actually born with this power and it
is one of the most important secrets in
the entire story because if anyone evil
such as the world government or someone
like the emperor a Blackbeard were to
learn about shirahoshi's Powers they
would definitely try to capture her in
order to use that power and really just
to hammer this in this power is
absolutely ridiculous I mean just look
how massive these sea kings are like
these are absolutely an island
destroying power if not more which now
brings us to pluton which at this point
we finally know is located deep deep
beneath wano country and while we still
do not know what the weapon actually is
there is a rumor that it was actually
some sort of ship since Frankie once had
the blueprints to a ship that could
counter pluton however there's actually
some mystery about all of this because
apparently pluton can only be released
once the borders of wano are actually
open now what that exactly means we
actually aren't quite sure but it very
likely has to do with destroying the
giant walls that keep the original wano
separated from the rest of the world and
now since Poseidon is a power to rule
under the Seas and pluton is likely a
ship to dominate the surface of the
ocean then it makes sense also name-wise
that Uranus would be a power that rules
the air and there's a bit of a manga
spoiler but we actually got the clearest
hint of Uranus's power back in chapter
1060 of the manga when the world
government secret ruler Unleashed This
truly terrifying power that destroyed
the entire Kingdom of lulua and I mean
this is literally an island destroying
power literally which is pretty strong
evidence that this is an ancient weapon
or at least something that was based on
one and what's really scary here though
is that this weapon seems to be in the
hands of the world government and it
does make me wonder if it was this power
that helped them defeat the Ancient
Kingdom back during the V Century in the
first place and now if you've been
paying attention throughout so far you
know that the world government was
formed by 20 original rulers yes I'm
going to say that like still five more
times in this video and we do actually
know who many of these families were
originally in including the nefatari
family and the dony hot family and very
recently in the manga we also learned
the names of many more of these founding
families but beside their names what's
actually even more important is what
they actually chose to do after they
defeated the ancient Kingdom which was
of course to leave behind their original
ruling islands and move on to the top of
the grand line to become the celestial
dragons and there are actually theories
that these new Gods as they like to
think of themselves moved up there
because it was the original location of
the lunarian tribe and if you remember
the lunarians were actually considered
the previous gods of the world so this
was like a big gigantic sign to the
world that the 20 rulers were announcing
themselves as the new gods of the world
and this actually brings us to another
very interesting bit of History because
these rulers all originally agreed to
rule together instead of appointing a
single ruler king or queen to rule them
all together and that was actually
symbolized by this very mysterious chair
or Throne called The Empty Throne which
officially no one is supposed to sit in
and to take it one step further each of
the founding families placed a weapon in
front of that Throne to show that they
were actually basically laying down
their weapons to all work together now
of course we do know that all of this
was basically one giant scam because at
one point the secret ruler emu took
control and is now considered the
supreme ruler of the world however we
don't really know if this is how it was
right from the start or if emu took
power later on in fact what makes this
even more mysterious in a lot of ways is
that emo is actually from one of these
founding families so it's pretty fair to
assume that emo was one of the original
20 rulers or it is also possible that
they are descendants of whoever took
power sometime after the world
government was formed but we don't
really know for sure at this point quite
yet however I actually just lied when I
said that all of the founding families
went up to live on marijua because one
family decided to give up their right to
become World Nobles and stay behind on
their home islands and that's of course
the nefatari family and as we learned
recently in the manger their family
ruler at the end of the vo century was
called nefatari Lily and while there is
still a ton of mystery surrounding her
we have some pretty strong hints that
she actually ended up betraying the
world government in some sort of way
most likely something related to the
poneglyphs but all of this meant that we
have some vital questions that still
need to be answered about the early
years of the world government and we'll
get into more theories about this lore
in just a moment but honestly at this
point it's probably a good thing that
the celestial dragons mostly stayed away
from the rest of the world because as we
learned from doflamingo's flashback when
his Celestial Dragon family decided to
come back and live with the common
people they were instantly rejected and
nearly executed by a mob of common
citizens and even though though Flamingo
survived this incident the celestial
dragons refused to let him back into
marijua because his father had already
renounced their status as World Nobles
so yeah these Nobles are both truly
cruel and they also hold grudges but
they also have the absolute power in the
world to enslave people murder and waste
extraordinary amounts of money and
actually one of the best examples of
this is this random bridge where Robin
was actually sent after Saba ODI this
bridge is called tequila wolf and its
story is that sometime about 700 years
ago some World Noble ordered that a
bridge be built between two islands and
here they are still building it all
these years later now we don't exactly
know the purpose of all this it could
have just been a random wish that they
had but I do kind of wonder if the
bridge actually ends up serving a
greater purpose here because if you
think about it we do know that the Seas
especially in in the grand line are
ruled by people who can sail Like
Pirates and Marines but maybe the world
government decided to make this bridge
so they wouldn't need to rely on ships
that could easily be attacked by Pirates
just a thought and another piece of
History that's really interesting is
that sanji's family the VIN smokes
founded their Kingdom around 250 years
ago in the north blue and while they
eventually ended up losing their rule of
the North Blue itself they recently
played a really important role in the
development of cloning technology and if
you ask me this is just an insane
development in the entire one piece
World in particular the VIN smokes
specialize in mass-producing clones to
fight in their mercenary armies and
believe me there are even crazier clones
coming up in tier level four but did you
even know that some parts of the one
piece Community once thought that Luffy
might in fact be a clone as well crazy
right but I mean you never know and in
fact Luffy's family lineage has always
been a very big mystery we do know that
he has his Grand fell the GARP and his
father Dragon who is the leader of the
Revolutionary Army but we've never known
about his mother which does mean that
now is the perfect time to throw in my
personal favorite theory that crocodile
is actually Luffy's mother and if you've
never heard of this idea it comes from
the fact that crocodile and Ivanov who
is a gender morphing officer of the
Revolutionary Army have some sort of
secret that they won't tell anyone and
so basically the idea is that once upon
a time crocodile was a woman who gave
birth to Luffy and then had ivankov
changed them into a man and as dumb as
this sounds there's actually a ton of
evidence for this Theory but I'll just
leave it at that for now because it is
time now to dive head first into the
chilly depth of tier level four which is
lore that you would really only know if
you are a hardcore fan of the one piece
story and what better way to start this
off then by discussing one of the rarest
abilities in the entire story The Voice
of all things now maybe you already know
some of the basics which is that the
voice of all things is this mysterious
power that allows its users to somehow
hear and understand the voices of
creatures and objects in the one piece
world for example when Luffy was about
to destroy this giant ship he heard the
sea Kings telling him to stop and while
he couldn't himself communicate back he
could basically understand what was
being set other examples include when
the future Shogun of wano MOSI could
understand and commun Comm unicate with
the giant elephant sonisha but beyond
that the voice of all things can let its
users understand even written texts such
as that on the poneglyphs which they
wouldn't normally be able to read
however that's of course not to say that
these users understand the messages
perfectly it's more like they get a
vague sense of what's being communicated
if you get my drift but what you may not
know is that there appears to be levels
of skill with this ability as well for
example Roger himself used this ability
to understand the meaning of many of the
poneglyphs by himself which let him to
go back and find others on top of that
people like Momo and his father Kazuki
Oden could clearly understand the voice
of the elephant sonisha whereas Luffy
could usually only hear a sort of
unrecognizable voice now to get to the
low side of this there are theories that
this ability is actually caused by a
super strong observation hockey and
other theories that this power is tied
to certain descendants of the ancient
Kingdom genetically but we really don't
quite know yet for sure now one crazy
bit of lore that you may have never
heard of is that the one piece world
might not always have been mostly
covered in water and while this hasn't
been officially confirmed yet there are
some truly powerful hints that this is
possible for example the original wano
country was lost underwater as we saw at
the end of the wano arc this happened
because at one point wallts were erected
around wano itself and then rainwater
eventually filled the space between the
walls Plus in chapter 115 way back at
the early stages of the story we
actually learned that dinosaurs once
freely roamed around the world but now
they are isolated on this island so it
would make sense to me at least that the
world used to have much more land
exposed and then some natural disaster
or not so natural disaster happened that
caused the world to flood and so now you
might be wondering what kind of natural
disaster could do that but we actually
have a clue from chapter 1089 of the mon
and fair warning that there will be
manga spoilers for pretty much all of
the remaining lore from here and out so
in chapter 1060 we did see that Kingdom
of lulua erased by this mysterious power
but what's even crazier is that in
chapter 1089 we actually learned that
this event somehow caused the sea level
all around the globe to rise by one
meter which at first maybe doesn't sound
like a lot but man if you calculate how
much water that actually is and what
that would actually mean if that
happened around our world you get an
insane amount like four quadrillion
liters of water like what how is that
even possible from this one single event
and if it was really caused by using
this deadly weapon just imagine if this
weapon was used over and over and over
again I'm just saying it isn't too
insane to think that the world might
once have had a lot more land and then
steadily stuff was eradicated sea levels
Rose and now it's all Island
now of course this is speculation but if
you want an absolute connection to the
disaster that now wiped out lulua look
no further than this giant gaping hole
below Anna's Lobby I mean those holes do
look strikingly similar right so we do
have to assume that this same weapon was
used at least once before and caused
this giant hole underneath an's Lobby
and so we have to ask ourselves then
what was there that got wiped off the
map well for one it could have been the
actual home island of the the ancient
Kingdom or some other very important
location like maybe love tale just
saying it could make a lot of sense why
no one has found it yet if the legendary
Island really is at the bottom of a
giant hole surrounded by world
government facilities now if that was
surprising to you just wait until you're
hear this next bit of lore because
recently during the egad island arc we
learned that the past civilization was
way more technologically advanced than
the current ERA and even the genius
scientist Dr Vap pun told us that he is
barely catching up to the technology
that actually used to exist in the
distant past now of course we can assume
that VAP Punk is talking here about the
time before the void century and the
founding of the world government which
when you really think about what that
means is completely mind-blowing but to
take things even further it is wildly
assumed that the world government were
actually the ones who erased much of the
technology from the world on purpose to
begin with and while this could
certainly be possible I would be very
care careful about assuming that the
world government did this all for evil
reasons I mean I mean we've all seen
stories about Advanced civilizations
that eventually get wiped out or wiped
themselves out because of Advanced
Technology or evil robots so maybe the
world government did the world a favor
if they truly did rid the world of most
of its technology or maybe that's just
how it's easier to control people don't
give them access to the most advanced
technology however with this knowledge
that the world used to be more advanced
we open up some truly incredible
possibilities about the lore of the
ancient world for example we already
discussed that at one point the winged
people of skypia and shandora once lived
up on the moon but that doesn't mean
that they always live there to begin
with in fact you might say that they
fled up there to escape oppression just
like the minks moved up to zunisha and
the fishermen moved under the sea and
with the advanced technology of the past
this makes a lot more sense that maybe
there was some sort of spaceship to take
all the wing people up to the Moon after
all there are space pirates in one piece
although we also have confirmed that the
golden city of shandora which was the
home of the wing chanion tribe was
around 1,100 years ago so clearly they
came down off the moon well before the V
Century apparently due to Resource
problems but on top of that would you
believe that devil fruits might actually
also be Technology based Creations
basically biotechnology I mean just
think about it we do know that
artificial devil fruits were created
using current technology and while some
were better than others can you just
imagine the possibilities of much much
more advanced societies and the powers
that they could potentially create after
all there is a quote Even in our world
that if technology is Advanced enough
it's basically indistinguishable from
Magic plus now that we're discussing it
I even wonder if this technological
advancement is what allowed humans to
eventually overthrow the lunarian race
in the first place because remember that
the lunarians were considered basically
Untouchable Gods so something had to
change in order for mere humans to
basically wipe them out and I can
certainly imagine the new technology of
devil fruits playing a major role in
that now as exciting as all of these
possibilities are let's bring this back
to some factual lore that we know from
the story because one of the oldest
events that we know of in the entire
story of one piece is the birth of the
giant elephant zunisha they were born
well over 1,000 years ago and were
closely allied with the legendary Joy
boy however at some point zenisha
committed a crime so bad that they were
forced to walk the oceans forever now
this is the interesting part here though
because while we don't know what crime
zisha committed we might be able to
guess based on its behavior during the
wano arc because if you remember zunisha
briefly came to wano right as Luffy
awakened gear five but then it left
before it could do anything important
and we can guess that zunisha left
because the future Shogun Momo decided
that it was way too early to open the
borders of wano So based on this we can
guess that zuna's main role was to open
the borders of wano which most likely
means destroying the walls that were
once built around it which is just the
perfect job for a massive Island sized
elephant but the amazing thing is that
we can connect this to what we discussed
earlier about pluton just a recap we
were told that pluton could not be used
until the borders were open so that
might mean that zenisha is the key to
unlock bling pluton or maybe pluton is
literally buried in the walls and they
need zenisha to break it open kind of
like the one piece version of the
rumbling maybe I don't know and so to
tie this all back to Zena's crime I can
just imagine that zunisha was one
supposed to help the ancient Kingdom by
using or unlocking pluton but they
failed to do so and were then forced to
walk the earth as punishment however
that is not all about this ancient
elephant because there are some crazy
ties between the elephant and the one
piece treasure treasure that are just
too spicy for tier level four so we'll
save them for the next tier and in fact
what should also be hidden probably from
history is that dress Rosa has a very
dark past when it comes to racism that's
because the donkey Hol family that
doflamingo is part of actually ruled
dress Rosa before the void century and
during that time they Enslaved the
entire tribe of the tonata dwarves and
forced the dwarves to work as slaves for
centuries this really only ended once
the donkey hot family moved up to
marijua after the void century and it
was this time that the rku family took
over leadership of the island and ended
up freeing those slaves which led to 800
years of peace until the warlord D
Flamingo part of the donkey hot family
came back and took back the throne and
now speaking of special races in one
piece again during the hul island arc we
actually learned that big mom's dream
was to make a paradise for all of the
races of the world and she almost
succeeded because members of basically
every race lift in hulking Island except
for three very special ones first are
the Giants who hated big Mom after a
potential marriage between their King
Loki and one of big mom's daughters
didn't go quite as planned so you won't
find any of these large folks walking
around there the second missing race was
revealed during wano to be one of the
lunarians which actually makes sense why
they weren't any in big mom's territory
because kaido's right-hand man king is
technically known as the last one still
alive and the third missing race was
finally revealed during Kuma's flashback
which is the race of Buccaneers
interestingly enough these people seem
to be a sort of crossover between Giants
and humans due to their incredible size
and strength and just like the lunarians
there is only one confirmed member of
this tribe left and that is the former
warar turned cyborg slave Kuma however
there is actually one other living
creature at least still with Buccaneer
blood and that is the saaim espar now to
be fair esar is a genetically modified
clone not a fullon Buccaneer but I do
wonder if somehow this saaim will play a
massive role in restoring the buccaneer
race at some point in the story and
while we're talking about the saaim
anyways at this point now might as well
be as good a time as ever to mention
that these creatures are the only ones
in the one piece world who have devil
fruit powers without ever actually
eating one now before we get too far
away from the Buccaneers too quickly
here we also have to mention the
mindblowing possibility that the ancient
figure NAA was actually a member of the
buccaneer raise himself in case you
don't remember NAA and joy boy are often
referenced when discussing the same
person from the void Century but we
don't actually know that they are the
same person all we do know is that
elephant zisha declared that Joy boy had
returned at the same time that Luffy
awakened his naika devil fruit now one
thing that is certain though is that the
buccaneer Rays knew about NAA and
basically worshiped him as their savior
plus if you look at the giant Frozen
straw hat in the top of marijua it makes
a lot of sense now that this head would
fit on the head of an extra large human
like a Buccaneer rather than a full siiz
giant so yeah lots of signs pointing
towards a connection between Joy boy NAA
and the buccaneer race before we go into
the insane lore of level five though
let's head back to Mario for a second
because there is of course this
mysterious line about the National
Treasure of marijua and this was
revealed by doflamingo himself but we
never got to learn what it actually is
it could be something that we've already
seen like the secret ruler of the world
emu the mega weapon that destroyed
liloia or the Frozen straw hat that we
just discussed another really
interesting option is that it could be
some of the Frozen Warriors of the past
I mean why else keep a giant secret
freezer or maybe it is something even
more insane like a secret devil fruit
tree that could be the original source
of all devil fruits call back to the eve
tree from earlier and what we don't
don't really know for sure one other
really interesting bit of lore about the
devil fruits is that there is some sort
of hint that devil fruits may have a
will of their own this kind of ties into
the whole idea that devil fruits have
some sort of spirit or soul of their own
and they will naturally seek out people
who represent core ideas of that fruit
and the first clear hint that we got for
this was back in chapter 1044 when the
guro said that it seemed like the NAA
fruit had been evading them for the past
800 years even though they had been
trying to capture and when we see Luffy
first Awakening at fruit it legit seemed
for a moment like he was possessed by
some kind of maniac spirit that he
literally could not stop laughing so
don't be surprised if we find out later
that devil fruits actually possess some
sort of spirit or soul in themselves
maybe connected to inherited will as
well however we can leave tier number
four without bringing up one of the most
mysterious and least talked about Topics
in the entire story I'm talking about
this thing like seriously what is this
it has never been talked about in the
story and it's only ever shown on
Roger's ship we do know that he had it
after reaching lar Island which is the
second to last island of the grand line
the official last one and the only place
that Roger first learned about the
poneglyphs maybe he found it there I
mean we don't really know nor do we know
what it actually is for a long time
Community theorists thought that it was
a dragon or an ancient weapon but at
this point really who knows one thing
that we do know though is that it simply
has to reappear before the end of the
story and have some sort of meaning and
now as we dive down into the depth of
the second to last tier of the iceberg
to level five we are really getting into
lore and history that requires a ton of
deep analysis and even some level of
speculation and if you know all of this
already you're most likely a
professional one piece fan for example
did you know that just like the real
world many events in the one piece
worlds are actually cyclical which means
that they happen over and over again
throughout the centuries and Oda even
shows us this by having similar arcs
between the pre and post time skip for
example Alabaster and Dr Rosa are both
very similar in Alabaster a warlord
nearly takes over a kingdom but then was
stopped by Luffy and then in dress Rosa
a warlord did successfully already take
over a country before they were then
stopped by Luffy another example is
arlong Park and fisherman Island both of
which dealt with the issue of racism now
why is this important well because if we
take the idea that events happen in
Cycles in one piece then you can surely
bet that the events of the white Century
are going to be repeated in the present
Story the key difference here though is
that Luffy will most likely succeed
where in the past Joy boy tragically
failed and this will ultimately mean
that Luffy will be successful in uniting
all of the races of the world to live
freely on top of the globe I mean he's
already basically done that with all of
his allies and friends that he has made
along the way and this time when the
world government attempts their great
cleansing as they call it Luffy and his
friends will be able to actually stop it
and while this great cleansing is sure
to be a truly awful event I bet that
you'll be surprised when I tell you that
the world's secret ruler emu may not be
as bad as we all actually think and this
takes some digging into his family name
which is neona again one of the 20
kingdoms who started the world
government now while we don't know for
sure this family name could have been
inspired by the Roman Emperor Nero who
has a ton of interesting history and
connections to emo himself first off he
ruled over Rome at the very end of what
is considered the Julio claudian Dynasty
just like emo is ruling over what will
very likely be the end of the world
government era in one piece top of that
Nero is usually considered one of the
worst Emperors for some awful acts that
he's said to have committed like burning
down the city of Rome however if you
really dive a little bit deeper into
into his history there are a bunch of
false myths and legends about Nero that
made him seem a lot lot worse than he
apparently actually was and I won't
really get into those here in detail but
if Nero really was the inspiration for
emu then there might be a whole other
story to EMU that we still don't know
some tragic history that they had so I'm
not saying they are a good guy but it's
definitely possible that they are a lot
more complex than just a simple evil
dictator and now actually speaking of
emu's family at this point in the manga
we do know many of the family names of
the original 20 rulers they are neona
Don nefatari as well as the names of the
five Elders which are Jay Garcia Marcus
Topman Ethan Baron and shepher and in
fact we may have also another founding
family the Garling family but they
haven't been officially confirmed as one
of the original 20 Kings though they are
Celestial Dragon so it would just make
sense and now to bring this all back to
nefatari Lily while we don't know what
exactly happened to her at the end of
the vo Century we do know that she
somehow ended up disappearing so it is
possible that she was just hunted down
and killed by the world government
another option is that she went on to
create the island of women Amazon Lily
since they share all the same name or
who knows maybe Lily even ended up
becoming emu in some sort of weird twist
either way something happened between
Lily and emu if they're not the same
person which let Lily to reject the
other Nobles and side with the ancient
Kingdom but before we move on from emu
one last shocking bit of lore is that
emu might actually be some sort of child
now we've long thought that emu and
theot might be immortal but there are
some actual clues that emu might have
had their age Frozen while they were a
kid for example their speech style in
Japanese is very similar to that of a
child plus if you've ever seen emu
sitting on the empty Throne they always
appear extraordinarily small now the
throne might just be massive but don't
rule out the possibility that they are
are just a child or someone with a very
very small body and while we don't know
exactly why they are so childlike but it
likely has to do with their very
mysterious power in fact we already have
a devil fruit that freezes your age
which is the hobby hobby noi and its
user was a child who literally forc
people to become Toy Slaves I'm just
saying that this is the kind of ability
that has already happened in the story
going in circles now this next bit of
lore stretches Way Way Back even before
the white Century because did you know
that the long arm and longle tribes have
been having some sort of ongoing War for
over 1,000 years crazy right while the
rest of the world was battling it out
during the void Century these dudes were
just over here kind of fighting each
other doing their own thing and I bet
that this next piece of floor might
honestly shock you and it has to do with
the current storyline that's because did
you know that we have never had a single
person actually drown in the actual
story of One Piece which is just
mindboggling if you ask me so surely
that means that Oda is saving this awful
fate for someone truly important in the
story right like maybe emu or Blackbeard
or something but if that happens at all
though it will very likely be at the
very end of the story which is also when
we should finally find love tail and
find the one piece however did you know
that Oda may have been laying clu about
the origin of Love tale and the ancient
Kingdom right in front of our is this
entire time let me explain we learned
during the skypia arc that part of the
island of Ja was launched up into the
sky and when you put these two pieces
together it forms the shape of a skull
classic pirate stuff right well if you
look very closely at the skull-shaped
map you might also notice that the left
eye of the skull is actually missing
which at first glance might not mean
anything I mean it is an island after
all and they usually aren't super
perfectly shaped but when you really
really dig into the symbolism of the
left eye throughout the story you will
learn that the Left Eye plays a
significant although quite hidden role
throughout one piece for one a missing
or closed eye shows up quite frequently
on volume covers that discuss the world
government void Century or the ancient
Kingdom for example in volume 11 Nami
here has her left eye closed and in this
volume Luffy and his crew defeated arong
save nami's Village and throw a massive
Feast to celebrate so really hitting on
the themes for freedom laughter and
celebration then we have volume cover 27
where Luffy has his left eye closed and
in this volume we have this panel of
Luffy looking like NAA dancing by the
fire as well as some other truly deep
connections about the Golden Bell and it
has a lot of similarities to the drums
of Liberation as well and there are many
more examples of left eyes being closed
during important volumes such as these
and throughout the regular storyline as
well but the important thing is that
during all of these volumes we are
learning important lore so clearly there
is a tie between the left eye and the
ancient lore of One Piece similarly we
have many important scars such as Luffy
Garb and zoro's being on the left eye
and Luffy's father's toat two also being
on the left side so all of this leads me
to believe that this missing left eye on
the island of GA is just too significant
to ignore whether that missing piece is
L tail or maybe the home of the ancient
Kingdom I'm not 100% sure but I wouldn't
be surprised if it showed up again in
the future however it is now time for
the deepest juiciest and darkest bits of
lur in one piece down at level six
starting with the fact that emu might
truly be a demon or some sort of
nightmarish creature there were hints at
this during chapters 1085 and 86 when we
saw his shadowy silhouette but even more
evidence is during chapter 1094 when we
see this demon-like transformation from
one of the godo St Saturn and I mean wow
like no one was expecting this and while
these abilities are still very much a
mystery it is truly making me believe
that the Goro and emu might just
straight up be Devils or demons or have
some other sort of demonic powers that
are kind of different from devil fruits
what's really interesting about the godo
and emu though is that we have been
explicitly told that they have natural
enemies in the Declan now I'm sure at
this point you know that there are many
people all around the world with the
initial D such as Monkey D Luffy and his
family they're also gold D Roger and his
son Ace Plus the giant here is also ad D
even someone like law has the initial D
and we recently learned that nafari Lily
was actually nefatari dily which means
that vivv who the draw has befriended
earlier in the story is technically also
a member of the D Clan so clearly all
these D clan members are not all related
by blood but you may be surprised to
learn that we got a really big hint
about the origins of the Declan in a
brief recent flashback because in
chapter 1085 we learned that luff and a
actually told Salo that he could have
the D initial in his name too since he
was technically their friend and while
you might think that they are just
messing around as kids I highly doubt
that Oda would just throw this in there
if it didn't have any real significance
later on so it might very well be the
case that the Declan were a bunch of
friends who baned together and adopted
this secret initial in order to stand up
for their beliefs however this next bit
of LA is even more secret because it is
now time to talk about the important
role of whales in the story we already
mentioned laboon and how he was waiting
at the start of the grand line for his
friends to return but did you know that
there are many other connections between
Wales and love tale for example in
chapter 8 there was a whale fountain in
the same chapter that Nami is looking
for a map to the Grand line then at the
start of the grand line where we first
learn about L tail laoon is literally
the first thing that the crew sees and
then what happens when they enter the
second half of the grand line you
guessed it a pot of whales appears as
well then the first time we see a road
poneglyph it is literally inside a whale
tree so clearly Oda is making it a point
that whales are an important piece to
this whole puzzle here and on top of
that we know that whales love music and
in particular the song Bing sake or as
they dubbed it now in English Bing sprew
which I don't really like so Bing socket
is which is a pirate song that is
connected to the one piece now you might
be wondering what does this all have to
do with the one piece treasure well
let's go back to laboon for a second
because when the crew gets trapped
inside of the whale they meet the Doctor
kocas Who is taking care of laboon from
the inside and we do know that krocus
was part of rogers's crew when they
found the one piece and he had his own
little island inside of laboon so one
idea is that all of this could be hints
that the island love tale itself is an
island inside of a giant whale and when
you combine this with the deep water
currents that we learned about in
chapter 604 it all adds up to a very
good explanation for why only Roger and
his crew have been able to find love
Tale in over 800 years which is because
the island itself might have actually
been hiding inside of a whale that has
been hiding in the deep water currents
and can only be found using a certain
method described on the road poneglyph
and it really all fits with the idea of
Wales and friendship especially since we
know that the ancient Kingdom already
had a connction with other giant
creatures such as zunisha and now while
this is of course partially at least a
theory we cannot deny that the clues are
really there just like how I know that
if you've been watching the entire time
until now you either absolutely love one
piece and have nothing better to do or
you're just slaving away in the
background doing your chores right now
or working and just listening to this
and I mean lucky for you even though
this video is over I have the perfect
thing to keep going for you with with a
massive one piece Theory Iceberg video
this time which you can watch by simply
clicking right here shks for watching
good luck whatever you up to right now
and I will see you in the next one
thanks for watching till the end